hello um this is priyana trajan the
current director of the frankie program
in science and the humanities
i am utterly delighted to invite you all
to a fantastic talk today as uh that's
part of our mapping as knowing um
lecture series that's been ongoing for a
couple of years
and
the title of our talk today is mapping a
polycentric history of renaissance sound
and our speaker is professor victor
coelho
and before we start and i give
a feeling introduction to victor i would
uh first like to thank
our benefactors mr and mrs richard and
barbara frankie
who i think are in attendance this
afternoon they have supported a host of
interdisciplinary activities at yale
and
the frankie program in science and the
humanities is one of the flagship uh
programs that they've supported and uh
we are really um
benefiting from uh their generosity
so i also want to remind everyone that
we are recording this event as per usual
now and that all participants will
therefore have to have their videos
muted for the duration of the talk
and please feel free to submit your
questions at any time in the q a feature
we will um
tackle them at the end of the talk and
uh
dr thai camp or i will read them out
for the speaker at the end of the talk
so um our wonderful speaker today is
one of a preeminent musicologist who
also happens to be a performer victor
coelho he's the professor of music and
director of the center for early music
studies at boston university
he specializes in 16th and 17th century
italian music as well as popular music
his areas of research include
renaissance and baroque instrumental
styles popular music interdisciplinary
approaches and cross-cultural
perspectives
as a specialist on popular music he's
interested in blues rock history
improvisation
and performance more generally and
broadly and appears regularly in digital
and print media
as of 2017 victor is also president of
the saturday club
uh founded by ralph waldo emerson in
boston in 1855 and that is where i had
the pleasure and the honor of meeting
him first he has held several visiting
appointments um at the university of
wisconsin-madison they call nomal
superhero in paris and cornell
university he was also a visiting
professor at villa tati in florence and
he also taught at the university of
calgary where he was named university
professor
and uh prior to um
taking up as the director
of the early music study center at bu he
was the
associate provost for undergraduate
education
and he was also the principal author of
the university's one bu report on
undergraduate education as you can see
he has several important commitments
both to music to pedagogy and
academia in general he's the author of
many
books
that include instrumentalists and
renaissance culture published by
cambridge music and science in the age
of galileo which is an absolutely
fascinating book
uh the manuscript sources of 17th
century italian loot music
and the cambridge companion to the
guitar cambridge companion to the
rolling stones
he is the luteinist and co-director of
the early music group el furioso and his
recordings appear on the stradivarius
and takata classic labels
he tours regularly as a blues guitarist
with the rooster blues band
so without much further ado i would like
to turn
the podium over the virtual podium over
i wish you could be here victor in
person
so but we are delighted regardless
and uh let me turn over to victor to uh
for his talk mapping a polycentric
history of renaissance sound
thank you very much priya um and thank
you tai it's a pleasure to be here uh we
had started this
um conversation about appearing on the
series in 2020 and in march 2020 when i
was supposed to come uh that was when
everyone everything locked down um and
then next year they they wondered
whether i would come for a zoom meeting
a zoom talk and i said well i'd like to
bring an instrument or two so it doesn't
really work on zoom so um then a few
weeks months ago
priya wrote entire road said well we're
you know you can come live now and we
can offer you dinner and come on the
train and i said that's great i accept
then two days later they said no no we
can't have any visitors but by that time
i'd already committed so i just want to
show how wily they are really at the
frankie center um and uh i'm pleased to
be here regardless of whether it's zoom
and i figured out a way that we can hear
some music as well
i'm going to share the screen and we can
get going
the mapping of a metropolitan center and
its outlying periphery is both
geographically real and historically
construed
and the associations implied by these
terms have been highly influential in
the writing of both art and music
histories of the renaissance
at its most influential level the terms
have been deployed in historical
accounts to control the borders of the
field
to make decisions about what to admit
and what to own it
and to provide a systematic accounting
of history
one that is fundamentally narrated from
the center often through qualitative
comparisons with the so-called periphery
in a famous statement by the british art
historian kenneth clark
the center was the place for the
creation of art
leading to that style becoming the
dominant one
it is metropolitan at its center
but as it began to spread out to the
periphery it becomes more provincial
in short a style does not develop
universally over a region
it is the metropole a single unit that
stimulates its progression
this view was a point of departure for
two highly influential articles by the
italian historians carlo ginsberg and
enrico castelnuovo
who did not see a predictable
transmission of style from the center to
the periphery but rather the emergence
of a power dynamic between the two areas
in which the so-called retardedness this
is their word of the periphery is a
rejection of innovation and resistance
to the center
in the field of renaissance musicology
the notion of center and periphery
has essentially guided the manner in
which we map music history from the
early 15th century to around 1600.
it is a story of courtly centers of
patronage like ferrara or ecclesiastical
institutions like the vatican
rarely venturing further out into
domestic music the provinces or cities
in the veneto not named venice or once
in lombardy not named milan
this model has effectively subordinated
entire repertories even urban ones like
urban instrumental music
it has been used to ensure the primacy
of notated so-called permanent works
over improvisational so-called
evanescent pieces
even though improvisation was one of the
central techniques used to teach
composition in the 15th and 16th
centuries
and the center periphery model has also
been used to prioritize certain regions
of activity most notably courtly and
urban ecclesiastical cultures
in this talk i will suggest
a revision to the notion of center and
periphery by offering a new map of
renaissance music history based on the
concept of polycentricity
in which many centers can operate
simultaneously
characterized by both conformity as well
as individual and local styles both
written and unwritten vocal or
instrumental
i will focus on three case studies
the first is on the 16th century dutch
composer clemens nonpapa in order to
show how the dominant center periphery
model in renaissance musicology has
affected the reception of his work
i will then move to a case study about
instrumental music which provides an
excellent model for a polycentric
approach
and in my third example i will suggest
how a polycentric approach can even be
influential in editorial work through
the example of a new complete edition of
the works of the 16th century lootiness
francesco damilano that i've recently
begun
the renaissance composer jacobus clemens
known by his contemporaries as clemens
non-papa in other words clemens not the
pope as if anyone would have mistaken
him on the street as the reigning pope
clement vii
medici was born in the netherlands
around 1515
and became one of the best known
and most influential composers of the
16th century but his music is barely
known today
even to specialists of the period
clemens is barely given a name check in
the standard histories of of or
reference works
it is rare as well to hear his music
performed or recorded outside of a few
pieces
even by musicians who specialize in this
period and try to explore the many
uncharted areas of the 16th century
repertoire
clementi's contemporaries did not see it
this way however
and this is an important consideration
that should push us to revise the manner
in which we map our renaissance music
histories
he composed an astonishing amount in
every major genre of renaissance music
mass motet french chancel and in
compliance with the reformation he
composed over 100 song settings in dutch
his music ceases vividly on the texts he
chose in order to create soundscapes of
drama and depth
in addition
his work was arranged repeatedly by
instrumentalists lewdness and wind bands
mostly
who not only extended his fame all the
way to the end of the 16th century by
their many versions mainly for loot of
his vocal music
but also dispersed his music for a
rainbow of different classes of
musicians civic wind bands lutanists the
waylists these are uh lutonis in spain
played a similar instrument keyboard
players professionals and amateurs
throughout europe
so here is a composer who achieved
considerable fame in his day but of
whose vast musical output numbering over
500 works there's only faint familiarity
by renaissance musicologists and
performers outside of a few dozen pieces
then there is the problem of
transmission
his music survives in many formats
printed and manufactured sources
in dutch latin and french
in many different types of notation
and we must consider not only the pieces
that he wrote himself but also the
hundreds of arrangements made of his
music by other musicians
which introduced one of the central
blind spots of renaissance musicology
that i will return to later
in short his considerable output has yet
to receive systematic and consistent
attention
and overlooking that would be
inconceivable in art history for a
painter that was so prolific popular and
whose work remained in the rotation for
decades
nevertheless one wonders how clemens
whose works were standards on the hit
parade of the 16th century is a mere dot
a gas station icon plotted on the
accepted map of renaissance music
there are several reasons for this
the first is a conventional but
increasingly problematic map-oriented
history of renaissance music
in this account the central musical
language of the renaissance develops
from about 1420 to around 1477
with composers born and musically
trained in what was then northern
burgundy and what is now the area
comprising northern france and southern
belgium
this musical language
its genres and its compositional
practices were then transmitted south
over the alps
through the circulation of manuscripts
but more importantly by the recruitment
of many of these burgundian composers by
italian patrons to cities like milan
ferrara
florence
rome
and to some degree venice
in these mostly dual cities led by a
ruling family
considerable economic resources were
devoted to this recruitment of northern
composers and singers the assembling of
choirs the training of musicians the
production of manuscripts and for the
benefits normally provided to those
elite burgundian musicians now in their
employ a salary
lodging a horse
wine wheat and grain
and very often a generous pension
few of these composers remained in italy
for good and benefiting from the fierce
competition among patrons for their
musical services
most of these
made periodic returns to the north they
accepted positions along the way and
added more landmarks to the historical
map as they personally transmitted their
music along their travel routes and
composed new works that were often
aligned with local musical traditions or
honored particular patrons
the travels of joss gandy played easily
the most famous composer of this period
and the first one to achieve
international fame
offers a case in point
schoska is born in 1450 up here in
northern france
by 1477 we find him in exxon provence
working for the duke renee of anjou
um
in 1484
we find him working for the sports of
dukes in milan
there's a reference to him working in
hungary in 1485 a reference that is
quite persuasive actually
in 1489 he accepts a position with the
papal court
he returns to france working for louis
xii in paris
all in 1503 we find him in the court of
the estee cordon ferrara
and in 15 from 1504 to 1521 he returns
to close to his birthplace in conde
northern france
where he remained until his death but
even then he was directing the
circulation of his manuscripts
throughout europe um and almost had a
kind of individual
manuscript production uh organization
but this gives you a good idea of the
types of travels of a famous composer in
italy many times but then finding
other positions as well
with italian courts now acknowledged as
the main musical centers in the 16th
century the north retreats into the
musicological periphery carrying clemens
with it
clemens was born somewhere in flanders
and even though hardly any biographical
information survives he does not seem to
have ventured far from home
unlike many of his remarkable
contemporaries
letters suggest that he became
unemployable
because he was often or even mostly
drunk
and he seems to have lurched from job to
job and maybe this is why he's known as
clan was on papa perhaps after you know
he was drinking he
put on papal clothing and walked down
the street from tower into tavern
uh
from beginning with a position in bruges
he bounced around several smaller cities
but he was successful in the world of
publishing music and writing works that
had immediate and lasting appeal in
french latin and dutch
in addition to the way that the musical
musicological historical mapping cramped
clemens's place in music history
a second reason is the result of another
kind of mapping
one that involves time chronology and
the notion of progress
an unfortunate but durable musicological
narrative of 16th century musical
progress places clemens historically
within a distinct group of so-called
post-javascan quote-unquote composers
sentencing him to a transitional period
of music history that was characterized
not by innovation and craft but by
playing to the demands of the commercial
market during this first boom age of
printing
and by an extended formalistic
application of the renaissance
contrapuntal technique of what's called
pervasive imitation
following but never succeeding josh scan
this group of so-called post-shos can
composers
generally appear as a lost generation so
clemens is born in 1510 between 15 10
and 15 15. joscan dies in 1521. but
following joshua's death he becomes more
famous than ever and um we have this jaw
scan afterglow that continues well into
the 1560s in which um joshua's catalog
of works increases exponentially mostly
by misattributions or people wanting to
place their music under the name of
joshua
but because of joshua's enormous
popularity during this period the
composers who were contemporary with
this period were placed by musicologists
in what's called the post-shaw scam
period so they exist with the in the
time of the same joshua afterglow
clemons dies in 1555 but that is by no
means when clemens's music also came to
an end
in the 1560s the next great as far as
musicology is concerned because composer
after joss gant was palestrina and
palestinian dominates this age of the
1560s and again it further cramps
clemens's career within this post-straw
scan uh
uh the post-oscar generation
but clemens's the arrangements of
clemens music reach a peak um starting
you know almost 10 years after his death
and lasting for another 20
20 years there's an enormous amount of
there of arrangements of clemens as uh
instrumentalists temporize his music for
the last few decades of the
16th century
so clemens was essentially a
part of a lost generation who
essentially kept the seat warm for the
great counter reformation composers
palestrina and losses
the aesthetic quality of clemens output
became and remains grossly undervalued
in this pervasive and discontinuous
historical narrative
one that only took into account his
sacred music not the larger impact his
music had through printing and as a
source for the arrangements of other by
other musicians
as an example one does not need to look
any further than the discussion of
clemens in gustav reese's music in the
renaissance of 1954 and subsequently
revised in 1959 the foundational text
about renaissance music history in
english equal in importance to frederick
hart's book on italian renaissance art
rhys discusses clemens
in a post-shaw scant chapter
tellingly subtitled richer iv and some
lesser men
a group that includes clemens
reese drew the map of renaissance music
into two large geographical areas
the first focused on the central musical
language of the 15th and 16th centuries
geographically positioned exclusively in
burgundy and italy
the second which he called music of
other lands
lumped together everything and everybody
else in england spain germany and
eastern europe
rhiza's division of history reminds us
of saul steinberg's famous 1976 new
yorker cartoon of the way new yorkers
view their city against the rest of the
world
the notions of central and peripheral
are clearly embedded here
both with recent steinberg as well as
the problems of this division
major composers that we recognize like
victoria talis bird and downland are all
extracurricular to reese's core language
despite their connections however brief
to the center
chronologically the renaissance is also
divided by reason to two further periods
the early renaissance beginning in the
early years of the 15th century and the
late renaissance extending through the
16th century and to the early years of
the 70s
rhys offers a substantial and often
detailed discussion of clemens music
more so than any other renaissance music
history to date
but its placing of clemens in the long
wake of post-joscaf followers created
for the composer a subordinate position
that has both endured and shaped the
historical narrative of the period
in another much more recent text on
renaissance music by the wreath students
allen atlas which is on the screen
a remarkable book but it's not on the
screen it's not i don't have that a
remarkable book in many ways that is
full of insights
he even wonders whether we should call
clemens clemens's period the no-name
generation
one of the most eminent musicologists of
the period richard tarruskin in a rare
act of compliance with other existing
musicological opinion also hangs clemens
in the post-jaw scan closet
clemens illustrates how the history
geography and travel of renaissance
music need to be scrutinized and aligned
more
closely clement's life runs contrary to
what we've accepted about renaissance
music history the center and the
periphery the traditional patterns of
influence and transmission
basically the conventional geomatics of
history
he did not travel far from his film and
he was not part of the burgundian
italian map
he was therefore excluded from
consideration
he came after shaskan and before
palestrina and remained in an area that
was not deemed progressive as the
musicological focus turned to italy
in order to show how inaccurate this is
this assessment is of clemens
let us look at the wide geographic
dispersion of one of his songs
not the song itself in its original
version for voices but by the
instrumental arrangements of this piece
made by other musicians of the 16th
century
the first one appearing in print in 1545
the first the song appears first in 1545
and the arrangements reveal the long
popularity of this work and how this
music got into the hands of many
different types of players themselves
creating arrangements for yet other
audiences throughout europe
this is from a manuscript in cambre uh
which contains sean song's french songs
by a number of of composers you see giza
land here and
um
claudin richard four and then right in
the box you'll see clemens mon papa
entitled jupren gray the song is one of
his most famous
um the beautiful handling of text um and
the syntactical connections between
texts rhythms and musical rhythms um
it's not surprising that japan angry
first published in 1543
durably survived in the hit parade for
another half-century
um
due in large part to the many
arrangements that were made in french
tablature italian tablature german loot
tablature citroen tablature and for
keyboard harp organ and vuela this on
the screen is um the first uh loot
arrangement of this piece
from
from lervin
and uh it's a it's an arrangement in
french tablature
these instrumental versions are
essentially translations of an original
text
or translation of an original musical
text
and like any translation they point at
new target audiences they arrive at new
geographical destinations and because
these arrangements are purely
instrumental that is they expunge the
original french text they are able to
cross cultural and linguistic divides
throughout europe
here's the transmission of this song
japan gray using the same
map
the original was published in 1539 as a
vocal piece
but by 1545
uh 1447
um we get this uh first publication for
luke uh and the publisher falls not only
publishes in 1547 he publishes it again
in 52 and then nine years later in 63
and then again in 71 and again in 82
basically every 10 years he's coming out
with this song this gives you an idea of
the demand that valez thought this song
um
this song had in his time
in 1547
we find a uh
a version coming out in trans trento in
italy by another lutonis named simon
ginsler
1556 this song is published in frankfurt
in 1557
in haiyan in spain
1562
into the estate by another lewdness a
blind luteinist from um from puglia who
settled into the essay named giacomo
gorzanis
in 1572 strasbourg gets published 1576
back to spain in valladolid
1577 surprisingly it took a long time to
get to 1577 to be published in venice
mainly because venice's um printing
presses were mostly publishing um
italian madrigals
in 1578 we have a uh we have it
published for a spanish loot in madrid
and 1583
we have the last
version in the 16th century printed not
even talking about what might have
existed in manuscript in nuremberg
even though all these instrumental
arrangements are different ranging from
highly ornamented and flamboyant designs
to literal reproductions of the musical
text's original song
these versions dispel the standard
musicological notion that clemens's
original vocal piece in french is the
central source
with these instrumental versions
most of them made years after clemens
death toiling in peripheral outposts off
the main grid
on the contrary these arrangements map a
wide polycentric geography of clemens a
song
one that allows for a multi-focal and
egalitarian view of the work across
international boundaries
they extend the distance that a work can
travel from its point of origin
from its composition as a vocal piece to
a transcription into other regional
notations leading to an adaptation of
the original work and finally a new
performance destined for different
audiences in diverse geographical
locations
to conclude this first case study
confronting clemens's brilliant music
from various musicological literary
historical geographical and even
performance perspectives
force us forces us to question
the hierarchy and priority that
underlies the conventional geographic
boundaries of renaissance music
it offers the chance to scrutinize such
notions as so-called central and
peripheral traditions
and source types
greater and lesser composers quote
unquote singular versus plural modes of
performance and the relationship between
original works and their adaptations
this leads me directly into my second
case study
which i've already hinted at
that is one major reason for the
exclusion of clemens from the narrative
of renaissance music
is that instrumental arrangements of his
work no matter how clearly they reveal
the wide international dissemination of
music
as we have just seen
simply don't count
instrumental adaptations expand the map
but because instrumental music was a
transitory and highly volatile repertory
much of it improvised before the 16th
century virtually all of it was either
improvised or memorized
led to its neglect in modern historical
scholarship
primacy has always been given to notated
vocal music but this neglect would have
seemed unthinkable for those who
experienced the soundscape of the time
the reality is that any history of this
music will need to develop a wide angle
rather than the narrowly focused view we
have used until now to include the
contributions of players that were
neither committed exclusively to
notation nor bound to an authorized
style of text or style of performance
renaissance instrumental music moves
across international and linguistic
boundaries it is the product of both
autonomous composition and arrangements
of other pieces often resulting in many
versions of the same work
at the textual level the derivative
versions made by many types of musicians
confront the critical and philological
methods that have generally blueprinted
how renaissance music history has been
studied
thus in examining this music one must
resist the temptation to prioritize
pieces and particular versions
since so many of them are tightly
interwoven with culture and function
across class
we must remember how much of the vocal
music of this period was arranged by
instrumentalists and popularized in
notated instrumental versions
for many listeners of the renaissance
these instrumental arrangements were
both the initial and most frequent
contact of say joscan's music
much more than for those who heard his
music during restricted services in
courtly chapels
in addition to their use of many
well-known dance tunes or songs and
their frequent roles as musicians hired
by the city
instrumentalists also played
a practical role in the geography of the
city trumpets sounding their instruments
when the gates of the city opened and
closed playing for civic processions
announcing visitors and the like
returning to the steinberg drawing it
shows the tradition it shows the
traditional perspective of renaissance
scholarship where the foreground
represents vocal music cultivated at the
institutional level whether court or
cathedral followed by everything else in
the distance
instrumental music permits us to create
a more detailed polycentric map of
renaissance music so that we can see
exactly what is on the other side
we are aware of the enormous expenses
courtly chapels needed to maintain a
choir a scriptorium and for the training
of musicians but what about the music
that was heard everywhere else
nuremberg and augsburg
the largest and most important cities in
southern germany but only half the size
of say bologna
supported groups of maybe four musicians
who played for the city a reminder that
the urban centers of italy were
consistently much larger than those of
the north and replete with funding for
music
although the bulk of archival data about
musicians is concerned mostly with
details of compensation rather than what
they actually played
it remains difficult to produce anything
like a pie chart showing the relative
expenditures of a town like nuremberg on
music
however for a small city like vinsheim
we can estimate that instrumental music
absorbed nearly 20
of the city's disposable yearly budget
which is considerable
these smaller cities also tell us about
the social rank of musicians their
origins and their personal geography
for example many musicians from alzberg
and nuremberg found lucrative careers in
florence and ferrara
some came from very small villages
the records of algebra between 14 and 15
1450 and 1500 indicate that several
musicians engaged by the city during
that time or from places that must have
had tiny populations 200 or less in
several cases
schrodenbach a remarkable case is that
of the minuscule lower bavarian town of
schrattenbach near augsburg which has a
modern day population of only just over
300.
it was probably distinctly smaller in
the 15th century
this was the home of the rock family of
musicians and instrument makers in 1473
klaus ralph provided the city of
augsburg with three pipers
at this time schrattenbach was such an
obscure place that the alksburg
accountants and scribes felt it
necessary to take the extremely unusual
step of describing the location in
relation to its neighboring city when
they listed the payment
paid for gulden to klaus
rauch in schottenbach which is two miles
from kempton
and kempton itself was one of the
smallest of the imperial city
these are just a few entertaining
examples from the archives but the point
is that instrumental music provides a
more detailed inclusive and frankly more
accurate modern map of renaissance music
in which roads clearly lead to other
roads and we see a more detailed network
of influences backgrounds and types of
musicians context and the even the
artisanal infrastructure of music
my final case study
um dealing with the ideal goal of
arriving at a polycentric map of
renaissance music involves a current
editorial project about the most
important important lutenist of the 16th
century francisco damilano one of the
many lutenists uh one of the many
luteinis whose birthplace on the musical
map is embedded in his professional name
francesco canova of milan
similarly there is marco of aquila
alberto of ripa perino the florentine
giovanni maria of crema lorenzo of pavia
anibale the padawan and so on
here i will briefly introduce how the
polycentric
um
have a polycentric model which does not
subordinate the periphery to the center
can incorporate the individual the
regional and even the idiosyncratic
idiosyncrasies of performance into the
addition
francesco the only musician to share
michelangelo's epithet of the divine
ildivino
i guess bette midler would be the third
was one of the most highly esteemed
musicians of the 16th century and the
most influential and important lewdness
of the renaissance
flourishing during a period when the
musical establishments of most italian
courts were dominated by northerners as
we have noted earlier
francesco was the first italian-born
musician of the renaissance to achieve
truly international fame
his music circulated widely in europe
through prints anthologies and
manuscripts and by the beginning of the
17th century his works had achieved a
classic stylus withstanding the dramatic
changes in musical style and
modifications to the instrument itself
that had rendered most of the 16th
century loot repertory obsolete
his music contained continued to appear
in english and continental sources a
century after his death
making an addition of francesco's music
and this would be the second
is notoriously complicated because of
the plurality
of source types and different regional
types of notation
authorized prints anthologies
student pedagogical books florentine
sources neapolitan sources roman sources
english sources posthumous sources
incomplete sources unreadable sources
pieces copy from a print pieces copied
from memory
truncated pieces ornamented pieces
pieces not clearly by francesco
but no piece is clearly not by francesco
but attributed to him anonymous pieces
that nevertheless passed the test
stylistically
um to attribute them to francesco etc
the sheer number of versions that exist
for us just a single piece can introduce
dozens of complex issues regarding
authenticity particularly among the 70
or so pieces that appeared after his
death
and of the pieces for which we are
relatively secure by francesco
which version does one use
the neapolitan version that contains
lengthy ornamented passages and unusual
dissonances
or the more conservative but also more
balanced venetian version
an attempt at a complete edition was
completed in
1970 which result resulted in
approximately 125 compositions
attributed to francesco
of which only 51 pieces appeared during
his lifetime
without reviewing the merits but more
importantly the deficiencies of this
edition that have made it imperative to
do a new one
suffice it to say that it was a product
of the rigid editorial philosophy at
harvard during the late 1960s in which
choices about what version to include or
exclude in addition were made by
adopting the central peripheral template
central sources being those that were
printed
even if they contained works of dubious
authorship and there were many
and manuscripts of elite pedigree
generally copied by a single scribe
peripheral ones like those copied by
students 17th century sources and prints
like the neapolitan one i just described
were
were not used even if they contained
superior readings
in this edition i will employ a
polycentric approach essentially
advocating for the use of many different
types of sources and benefiting from the
digital format of the addition that will
allow this
when pieces have multiple versions that
contain significant variants they will
all be included as a way to redraw and
expand the map of what of
to include who actually played francesca
muse francesca's music and to avoid the
trappings of the traditional center
and periphery model
this means that not only are cultural
regional chronological and textual
differences validated by their inclusion
the variants documents something that i
believe is critical to this project they
reveal different performances of the
work that took place over time
and space
and how players incorporated their
individual musical and technical
abilities
across a wide geographical spectrum
i thought we would hear one piece by
francisco i was going to if i was this
was live live i was going to come in and
play a piece but on zoom i do have a
recording of francesco
uh from a source that was used um it's a
it's a an important source um
that's called the sienna loot book even
though it it is now housed in the hague
and this is the it's a manuscript
version manuscript source and it
contains one of francesco's um funds at
richer cars right here at jakarta de
francesco
um so this is a recording i made i don't
know 15 20 years ago i think uh and i'll
you know this is an italian tablature
and i don't know how many people read
italian tablature so i'll just use my
cursor as kind of the bouncing ball as
we hear this piece
it goes from here all the way to here
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so in conclusion the act of creating an
inclusive and connective network of all
musical practices sung played written
and unwritten
quickly reveals flaws in the hierarchies
and priorities that have largely mapped
the geography of early modern music
history
but since jordan can also offer the
chance for revision that is to move
across the historically constructed and
still not outdated boundaries of central
and peripheral style peripheral
styles greater and lesser composers
singular and plural modes of performance
notated and improvised practices and the
border between original compositions and
their adaptations thank you
thank you so much victor for um
wonderful talk um
showing us how the sort of disrupting
this sort of dichotomy of the center and
the periphery
and
revealing to us that
geography
has played a really important role um in
establishing the notion of tradition
so if i may start with the first
question
so um i was curious with you know in
your three case studies were really
fascinating
uh because of how in the case of
francesco de milano and the other marco
de aquila you showed how
place is very much part of the identity
yeah
and
and um and and it also potentially um i
gather sort of informs style and even
notation perhaps
uh sort of a unif uh sort of a
uniformity so i was curious is there any
kind of you know given that there are
instrumental modifications over time and
changes on notation
is there any kind of universalism at all
or does it not really make sense to talk
about
um
sort of core um core ways in which you
could make connections across time and
across place yeah that's a good question
i mean there does seem to be a kind of
notion of progress that takes place
certainly in in certain centers in italy
um
perhaps one model for
for a universalism would be um towards
the end of the century when
printers begin to
to
to put together anthologies
and the anthology begins to then
bring together
works that were that were popular that
had circulated that were clearly
um
that were clearly
consumed
at many many different levels
and these anthologies were very
successful and they came out and i
wonder whether that might be
uh where a lot of these composers you
know receive sort of classic status
by being anthologized similar to
literature
you know and how uh poets and writers
become anthologizes and those
anthologies become you know standard
reading at institutions and pretty soon
that kind of
american literature comes into focus
northern literature comes into focus and
and that's how those things become
mapped and so it um we don't pay enough
attention i think to anthologies but
that's that i think would be one place
where i would start with this and
they're both manuscript anthologies and
um and printed anthologies and
manuscript ones are even more
fascinating because now we see a person
an actual person in this case the one of
them that i've studied as a young 17
year old florentine who puts in his
manuscript works from the early 16th
century all the way to some pieces of
his time works to sing works to play
works to play with his friends i mean
there's a there's a very interesting
aspect of here's my personal personal
repertoire here's my playlist
right this is my playlist and and
playlists are are good
is a good analogy because playlists do
not sit in one period of time they are
usually they come from various places
they've been they're suggested they're
they're they're people are tagging it
there's they're coming in so many
different ways and your playlist grows
in a very interesting fashion
these magical anthologies are in the
case some somewhat the same thing
so um
that's um
yeah
that's intriguing right that the
anthologies might be the place to kind
of track
so i had another question about sort of
the the center and the periphery right
and i wonder
um of course i'm not i mean you did not
talk about any women composers or uh
women performers
and i i mean are they just completely
absent from the sort of written record
though they existed obviously no not at
all in fact you know in the past few
weeks we've learned about some major
discoveries by musicologist laurie
strauss of um a whole book of of
madrigals um by a a very well known
now well-known female composer and there
are magical composers but the problem
there were lots of female luteness and
in the book that i wrote with keith polk
we devote um uh some some time to
understanding the issue of gender
in in terms of performance but
professional professional roots were
pretty much blocked where musicians um
female musicians tend to begin to thrive
in the courts of mantua and ferrara
during the late
late 16th century um
as uh as as magical singers virtuous so
magical singers and that was that put
them on the doorstep to opera in the in
the 17th century um and we have other um
you know we know about isabella deste
and other women of ninja means who
played loot and composed music i don't
think that i've ever found though a
piece that could be securely attributed
to a female luteinist um
so it was not that uh
that the women were potentially part of
the periphery we're still talking about
like a very um male composer performer
and yeah and and yeah and the
repertories associated with them you
know courtly repertories versus
non-quarterly repertories um you know
for example you know
we've not
other than a few people that i think
were on the zoom call
um you know music and
for
civic uses music in cities um
was not very much studied a lot of that
is improvised a lot of that is arranged
and when you bring in you know improv
improvisation and arrangement those two
verbs are fighting words for for many
people because they they indicate a type
of music that was what i call
evanescence that was that's fleeting
it's not it's not uh permanent
um
and uh and arrangements tend to be
considered as
uh corruptions
of a um and or texts and or texts
that that takes it out of the composer's
hands but there's no question that
composers understood that their music
was going to be arranged and um and
there are multiple versions of their of
their vocal music anyway so i think the
the periphery is is is quite complicated
it's both rural it's um classes of
musicians who are not elite musicians uh
they come from families um of that that
have been trumpeters for you know many
generations uh or lutonis um
they're loot makers you know there's a
huge
infrastructure of instrument makers that
we often don't consider that you know
especially in venice
uh and so the periphery you know
contains well what used to be called the
periphery scholars called perfect
contains all of that material um and for
and instrumental music in general has
has been relegated to that in
in many ways
yeah go ahead
yeah yeah i had a question if i may um i
wanted and please i'm showing my
ignorance here i had studied flu and
piccolo classically uh for years but i
am ignorant of tablature and mentioned
specifically italian tablature so
forgive me would you explain it a bit
more i it seems to be based more on a
numbering system i'm used to more you
know traditional notes
yeah i mean we we still we still use
tablature
um all the time if you buy a you go on
the internet and look for
you know um
the tablatures to hotel california
you'll get
20 of them all all wrong
but
uh so let's put up the fallaz here
okay so this is called french tablature
and the lines that go across from right
to left from left to right are not staff
lines those are the strings of the loop
one two three four five there's five
here
and then he'll put and then but there
are six strings on the loose so he has
to put the letters um for the for the
bottom string
below the staff you see where my cursor
is here
okay
okay so this is the top string of the
loop a g this is a the second string of
d here's an a there's an f there's a c
and then there's a g down here which he
doesn't indicate mainly because he used
this font and he used this you know the
blocks for printing for many other uses
and
i don't think he had a template for six
lines of tablet chirp so he just did
five
um and he um figured out the rest the
letters indicate where you put your
fingers on the frets
so so a means that you play the string
open you don't have to fret anything
it's just an open string
b means you put it on the first fret
c means second fret d third etc so when
the letters are all piled up one on top
of each other that's a chord that means
that that fourth string is open that d
would be the third fret then you put
your finger on the third fret of the
third string and you put your finger on
the third fret of the second string and
you you get actually an f chord and then
you put the rhythms up here now the
rhythms only give indication of the
fastest voice at any one time
and so um
right here the fastest voice any one
time is what's going on in the top
string
right and in other places
like in the piece that i played later um
see here
sometimes
uh there the fastest notes are on the
bottom
okay so this is italian tablature so
italian temperature reverses everything
now there's no no
there's no letters now there's numbers
okay so now the a that we saw in french
tablature becomes zero
so zero is the open string and one is
the first fret the second is the second
fret that makes a little bit more sense
but that's not the only difference now
the first string is down here
the highest string
and the lowest string is up here
so they reverse that
so you have to kind of you know learn
both of these tablets then this german
tablet which assigns a
unique letter to every single fret and
every single node
um typical
so here's a good example of the lowest
voice having
all the rhythms so you just put the
rhythm there and you play all that stuff
and then it goes to the top so this is
it's a visual depiction really of
where you put your fingers and um the
irony is that tablature was invented to
make things easy so people did not have
to read staff notation but it's exactly
what has presented this what has
prevented this repertory from being
widely known in the musicological
literature
and composers at renaissance composers
in particular would have been conversant
in
german french and italian
i don't think anybody outside of germany
was conversant
um and that's why that's why german
tablets were faded by the early 17th
century and what was what what was left
in the end italian tablature kind of
fades in the early 18th what was left
was was was german it was french it was
french in the end
so
very good question those are those are
good ones
so i actually have another question
which is so um
so victor when when really does the sort
of the pattern of patronage say for luke
music sort of change from
the court and the church to more sort of
music for the masses or was that always
there none of the glitz were music for
the masses i think that there's you know
this
it's still the one percent
okay you know or the middle class you
know by the by the 16th century i i
don't think it i think
the the the shift from the loot to the
to the spanish guitar there you're
getting because then they're saying no
all the barbers play them and it becomes
very easy to play and then you get a
huge huge um difference in terms of of
class of of players but that takes us to
the early 17th century and that's taking
place in spain and in other parts of
italy um
so so uh but the loot remains you know a
noble courtly instrument it's
um it's it remains a
i think for
you know well-educated youth
it doesn't seem to have had a
a kind of um
association you know with brothels or
you know the kinds of things that we see
with the guitar and other instruments
you know you look at all the broil
painting paintings you'll never see a
loot you'll see bagpipes and you'll see
things like that but
yeah and and what about um you know
since you are interested in
cross-cultural musical influences
um
are there versions of the loops that are
played around the world
oh yeah i mean on the boat
in the indian
yeah i mean so that's where it changes i
mean and and that's another problem with
about the center and periphery is that
you know when i was a graduate student
you would have committed academic
suicide by saying that you want to study
you know new world music of you know
that was exported from
from spain or what i did in goa and
looking at portuguese music that ended
up in goa india um
but that is a huge huge uh trove of
information um that's there and the
first boats that came to india carried
instruments um they had small portable
organs right
and so so so that's what leads to the
harmonium
in the end
these these these organs um and so these
these organs that we call portative um
these tiny small little ones that you
can place on a table which are you can
see in many medieval portraits those are
some of the instruments that were used
to accompany chant when they had mass on
the boats and when they came to india
and they set up churches
they brought those instruments um
probably the english were the ones who
uh were were very influential in the
harm the organ
becoming
associated with a harmonium but the
harmonium is essentially a portion organ
right
yeah and it's probably the only one of
the only fixed pitch
instruments in india all the other ones
are are variable pitches
the um you know but in terms of motifs
and actual composition content of
composition
and uh sort of structure
are cross-cultural influences
discernible like i mean
did what did you know
um
did the sort of um
did the mixture of cultures in spain
in the 13 you know 12th 13th 14th
centuries with the moors did that
actually have impact on these traditions
yeah i think that you know when you have
uh for example in the new world new
world polyphony what's interesting is
the choice of texts and liturgical texts
that they venerate things that that were
particularly venerated among new
catholics right um newly baptized
catholics etc
were those are the ones which are very
different from the types of saints that
you know you might have written texts
for in in um
in uh what about the sounds themselves
the sounds themselves so um in india
uh
we have a few manuscripts but they're
all from convents
they're all written for very high voices
um
and so
um and they tend we all dedicate the
same michael uh the protector so
uh
there's there's a lot so there's that
and whether that
whether that lets us know about
particularly indigenous qualities it's
not clear because
you know these are written texts that
that come from
so the only thing would be the
the you know the texts themselves
the high voices um
because they're convents uh and um
and we don't have any written record of
the um
syncretic music that was very much part
of goa
around the 1560s and 70s before the um
trent and other
um bodies
pretty much
shut that down but there was a lot of
syncretic music making
and um the archives show
character
[Music]
instruments um and instruments of the
land
and so there was there was that as well
so there would have been i think of an a
an indigenous quality to music making
within these these institutions but
there's no
um musical record of those unfortunately
i mean because i mean i think the so for
example the indian oral traditions uh
musical traditions
you know seem to have um
appeared quite independently right so
music and north indian classical music
right but
the argument is made that you know the
forms of music the forms of north indian
classical music like the guzzle right so
on these are very informed by poetry and
persian but these are or do or do texts
that go very very very far back yeah
exactly
exactly but it but the the problem is
the question i always have with indian
music is is performance you know does
harry potter is he playing a style that
is
100 or 200 years old or is he playing a
style that has somehow been frozen from
from 400 years ago right
when um
yeah and you know and the argument is
when krishna played the flute right i
mean i think the argument is often made
right when people talk about the
difference between indian classical
music and other traditions is that there
isn't as much room for improvisation
in that in indian traditions right
we're in nutrition we're outside of
indian traditions outside of indian
tradition okay well that that's exactly
what i was hoping to
thread that that in there that's one of
the things that has been
um
that is one of the things that has been
eliminated from
from uh from the writings about
renaissance music is that what how do
you talk about 15th century instrumental
music i mean my colleague keith polk who
i think is on the call
um and i devoted a fair amount of
space in our most recent book
and you have to work your way back
sometimes you have a source that that
that might reflect these traditions but
we have enough theoretical evidence
about how they improvised and how they
you know you went from one voice to two
voices to three voices to eventually
four voices improvisation is is
is a factor that's important all the way
through the end of the 18th century and
so
while it's you know
we recognize that now for performance of
the 15th and 16th centuries and 17th
we're now starting to um recognize that
for more and more so for performers of
the 18th and 19th century music
but no there's no question that
improvisation is that blind spot
right in musicology renaissance music
college
right unrelated question victor how
illustrated were the tablature uh
musical scores there there was an
earlier um
i think the first musical piece you paid
played looked like it had um some
illustrations on it i mean were these
richly
illustrated or not maybe
some were some somewhere the ones that
were that were illustrated
um were ones that uh the the
the
owner wanted to keep for posterity
and so a good example is one that um
i've just been working on
um calling this just loading here
that i've just been working on
so
this this manuscript
is one that i think that you this is in
the newbury library this is a manuscript
written by a venetian
a nobleman from from brescia
and he had an artist illustrate this
manuscript oh wow so it would so even if
it was lost if it had become lost um
somebody would keep it for
austerity
right and so but this is unusual
um
uh rarely are renaissance loot
manuscripts
given to a professional copyist or a
scriptorium or an illustrator this is
unusual
um for many reasons and i've done a
study of the images in this book but
this this might be one of the only ones
you know
there's a few in the 17th century when
they were in grave but as far as mascots
you can see this the birth of adonis you
know coming out of the tree
so there's all these classical
references to these things and they they
tend to be right at the very beginnings
of every piece you know um and then
later on the animals start attacking
each other
um
and it becomes and and you see a lot of
these
kinds of um
you know this this this decoration
uh that that you find um in venetian um
venetian books or ornamented books all
this kind of stuff so there's a strong
influence from the venetian
arabesques i think is what they're
called um from that tradition yeah
good good question this is gorgeous wow
really gorgeous
so um
i feel bad that we've been monopolizing
the entire time for questions so let's
let's wait and see if there are any uh
questions from the audience uh please go
ahead and type them in the q a
and um
you know
i mean i i could keep asking trying to
understand his stuff is so so
fascinating um
so i guess while we wait for someone up
else to muster up uh
courage to type up a question um
i mean i would like to sort of uh
continue
um
so how i mean you showed a lot of these
manuscripts right so
what you know
in modern day music what do you think
how should we preserve our musical
traditions now well they're all digital
right and so they are
how do you preserve the actual um the
actual item or preserve the tradition
say a tradition that
in a in a village that's rapidly being
modernized or something like that
both i mean both really right i mean you
have a recording that is digital yeah
but
the text the uh the actual musical
scoring of it and so on
i mean just scan copies i mean the you
know
vellum has survived quite well but it's
not not much anymore i mean i think that
the large collections in europe have
been on a project of digitizing now for
20 years
and during the pandemic it was
remarkable to see how i could continue
my work
by by being able to get complete
full-text manuscripts from most of the
major major libraries and um you know
there's an enormous amount of government
funding i've just signed off as a
reviewer for a very large one in germany
um that's probably the largest one that
i've ever seen
with the austrian national library in
tow and things like that but that that
is a win and those things are searchable
you know you can there's a lot of
metadata there's tagging and so it's
easy to to to to burn through those
those collections um you know with with
questions
and try to find stuff so in that sense
it's very good to have those digitized
because for analytical work it becomes
it becomes much much easier
um
uh yeah but in the in the day i mean i
looked at every single one of these
manuscripts
by hand and most of my colleagues did
too there was nothing there's no other
way or you looked at it on microfilm
but those those days are over as far as
the musical traditions themselves
i mean the older
older
um
history of ethnomusicology was that you
would try to preserve these traditions
but price by by preserving them you're
also recording them and you're you're
creating a kind of
intrusion i mean ellen lomax recorded
all of those blues musicians in the
south country blues players and the
musical just went to bali they went to
india
recorded and recorded
um
and then as tourism encroaches and you
see some of these villages
now stopping to play music and they're
musicians who played village music are
now playing in the hotels that's right
you know you could decry that and say
well this is so disappointing but what
you're seeing is a transformative aspect
of how music is being transformed go is
another great example you know the
the whole coastline is dotted uh with
with the five-star hotels and you go in
there and you find um people singing in
um uh singing in konkani
yeah uh traditional company songs you
know for tourists um and
the the interest now is how those things
have changed from early recordings you
know what we're finding out is in places
that play um gamalon instruments and
things like that all these hotel players
are playing much faster than they ever
had before because they've got to fit it
in from the people when they arrive on
the bus where they're stopping the hotel
to have you know some of some food and
hear the show and then go back on the
bus to the next event that's right so
everything has been transformed so in a
sense that the musical just saying let
it die you know and and and and see how
it see how it plays itself out right and
see what remains as a residue right
right rather than the old uh alum miriam
con the con concept of you know the
knight on the white horse who's going to
come in and record and save everyone
right
that's the white knight theory yeah
right
great uh thank you so much um
i think tai did you have any last
questions before we wrap up
i was curious i'm not sure if this is uh
historically correct but
what from what you presented
flourished most uh
in the new world when it was found
what kind of made it over whether were
there any well
okay
so in
in india they bought they brought
books of chance the early explorers
brought books of chant because they
needed to celebrate mass on on the ship
and when they got and they built a very
early church in saint catharines which
still exists with you know crumbling um
in old goa um
by 1540 uh they were bringing in
um
polyphony so this is chant now with
another voice i don't know what kind is
probably very simple two-voice
polyphony and they have a word for it um
you know canto dorgano you know
singing over the organ um so two voices
versus kanto xiaong which is chant
so that's a big development there
by the 17th century mainstream
jesuit music because the jesuits were in
goa
mainstream roman jesuit music from the
roman college is being sung
going the other way um there's a very
large large two very large collections
in in mexico city that our late 16th
early 17th century
um mainstream music but also containing
some composers that were trained in
mexico some indigenous composers that
were trained in mexico
um
uh so there's and that's that's been a
very important source for study
so we're so so it's there is a lot of
travel
um but all this all this kind of music
all of it required extensive training
right
and training requires an extensive
commitment of resources
and so and in a sense in the end you
know that for instance in india
the christian project really did not
did not survive i mean the article did
not take off really but yeah they didn't
all the letters that xavier sent back to
to to rome saying that you know he had
baptized ten thousand people you know on
the coast and things like that
he went to kerala and baptized another
five thousand those were all
exaggerations
we do have one question in the q a if i
may read it out
uh was there any music related to
specific events historical figures or
memories that people could interpret in
their own ways
well there's a lot of music that's that
was written for specific events these
would be what we have
you know are
you know um
large events institutional events you
know coronation
weddings et cetera weddings and things
like that
we yeah we do see um that music
begin to then trickle down into the
hands of
of um of domestic musicians so so that's
a that's a good point and a one example
would be
medici festival music these enormous
pageant you know celebrations with tons
of pageantry which went on for weeks and
weeks at a time when one of the medici
married somebody from
you know the hapsburg empire or from the
you know the french empire or whatever
but um
eventually that music began to trickle
down
uh and i've traced a little bit of how
it was but it got into the hands of
domestic players people who were
probably connected you know seven
degrees of separation from the court
um
and then that music was arranged and
some of that music you know which was
originally for four voices now appears
for
um for one voice and lewd accompaniment
so that's what that's what actually
happens so that is a transformation a
personal
transformation
of a
of a work for that person's own use
thank you
great um we should probably not uh
detain you any longer and uh thanks once
again victor thank you wonderful talk
and uh yeah so um
yes yeah i'll see you in may and um
really looking forward to when we can
welcome you to campus thank you i
appreciate that thank you very much and
thank everyone for
listening
thank you i also want to say thanks to
uh dr thai camp and brian mccoy for
helping us with the recording and the
recording should be available online
uh uh fairly uh in short order within a
week or so so
thank you
yeah thank you bye